la carrera para llegar a la casa de
nariño cobra fuerza en colombia
de las tres coaliciones que compiten en
las elecciones presidenciales la de
centro esperanza se presenta con cinco
precandidatos el ex gobernador del
departamento de antioquia sergio fajardo
el ex ministro de salud alejandro
gaviria el senador juan manuel galán el
senador jorge robledo y el ex gobernador
del departamento de boyacá
carlos amaya
la coalición centro esperanza reúne a
personajes provenientes de partidos de
centro y de izquierda
sergio fajardo que se presenta por
tercera vez a unas elecciones
presidenciales es el más opcionado para
hacer el candidato presidencial tenemos
que romper con el continuismo y elegir a
personas que hemos usado la política
para transformar vidas y ciudades
gobernando con serenidad rigor y
transparencia siempre esperanza se
presenta como un proyecto político en
oposición al gobierno del presidente
iván duque que según la coalición
abandonó el camino de las grandes
reformas el próximo presidente va a
tener que gobernar con personas que
piensan diferente para tener que tener
un gabinete representativo de todas las
fuerzas políticas si no lo hace así las
reformas que necesita colombia la
reforma pensional en un sistema
pensional que excluye al 80 por ciento
de la gente la reforma tributaria en
medio de dificultades crecientes que
este gobierno dejó hoy que no ha
solucionado la reforma a la justicia en
medio de un sistema completamente
congestionado y desbordado no se van a
poder hacer capacidad de unir
el discurso de centro esperanza se
enfoca en recuperar la confianza en la
democracia y garantizar los derechos de
los colombianos entre otros ejes
la coalición de la centro esperanza
nació hace dos años para proponerle al
país una nueva manera de hacer política
en donde el ejercicio coherente entre
nuestro discurso y lo que nos exigimos a
nosotros mismos lo vea reflejado con
sinceridad la ciudadanía el cuidado del
medio ambiente el cumplimiento del
acuerdo de paz de 2016 y promover el
desarrollo y la competitividad en los
sectores rurales indígenas y campesinos
son algunas de las propuestas de centro
esperanza que a través de la pedagogía
espera liderar el país pero en un país
altamente polarizado los integrantes de
la coalición de centro que además han
tenido enfrentamientos entre sí no la
tienen nada fácil frente a sus
competidores de las coaliciones de
derecha e izquierda